house prices are going to go up every
year for the next five years how do you
know if you're ready to buy a house
because if you're ready to buy a house
you need to buy now all right here's how
you know if you're ready you're out of
debt you have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses and you have a
good strong down payment 20 is
preferable because you avoid PMI if
you're a first-time homebuyer sometimes
you only put down five percent or ten
percent that's okay but you're going to
pay that stinking PMI get ready then
when you buy you buy on a 15-year fixed
where the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay well I
can't afford the house I like that's got
the granite countertops then you can't
afford that house hello you need to buy
a house you can afford that's a good
wise financial decision and you need to
buy now house prices are not going down